next speaker is a Kevin hotels about
learning as a tool father if you design
and beyond worst case so yeah I decided
in the title of this talk to to riff on
the title of the workshop because after
all it seemed to actually give kind of a
good outline for what I wanted to talk
about and I I promise actually had no
impact on the title of the workshop this
is just a happy coincidence and the
nature of this talk is going to be to
survey a lot of work that I've done with
a lot of different people are all at a
pretty high level my sense is that this
audience will be more interested in
hearing about the sort of high-level
structural takeaways from things that
we've done than walking carefully
through some piece of experimental
analysis so at the beginning of every
section I'm just going to have some sort
of call outs to to various papers to
kind of give due credit to my co-authors
in particular let me and note and some
co-authors who appear sort of throughout
the talk and and particularly among them
are Holger who's who's here and so the
motivating problem that that you know I
want to think about in this work is I'm
thinking about how I'm solving NP
complete problems works out in practice
and if you look at an algorithms
textbook for example how craftsmen 20
and all men and you'll hear that your
problems are intractable when they can
be solved but not fast enough for the
solution to be usable and we often hear
about NP complete problems being
intractable and in reality if that's
what we mean by intractable then the
reality is more complex because there
exists this whole literature in AI on
trying to find good algorithms for
solving NP complete problems and
although the best available methods
don't offer interesting theoretical
guarantees which might be where I lose
all of you and it's nevertheless the
case that these algorithms work just
astoundingly well in practice they work
really reliably well in practice as
we've heard from some of the previous
talks and nevertheless if we look under
the hood they also tend to exhibit
exponentially varying performance so
even when we hold size constant we can
see runtime
that on problem distributions that we
care about the range from milliseconds
two days so so there's clearly something
structural going on that that is
interesting to understand and necessary
to understand but on the other hand and
there's also clearly it would be the
wrong thing to just dismiss these
problems as being unsolvable so the
question that will motivate this talk
and that has motivated the research
going into this talk is asking how hard
is it to solve a given problem in
practice using the best available
methods and and this is tricky because
the best available methods are typically
really not amenable to analysis they
don't tend to offer theoretical
guarantees that we can do anything
useful with and in fact we can't even
necessarily take them apart you know we
can't even necessarily look at something
like cplex and know how it works you
know it might be in fact a trade secret
how the algorithm works we only get sort
of black box access to it and the upshot
of this work that I want to kind of
leave you with is even in such crazy
cases where formal analysis seemed
hopeless because I can't even look at
the algorithm and the instance
distribution I want to look at is again
not analytically described but may be
given to me only by samples it's
possible to take a statistical view in
which and we can answer such questions
with high levels of statistical
confidence and I guess holger's talk
yesterday I'm thinking about a very
different problem of scaling behavior
gave another sort of sense of what that
might look like to and try to give
statistical guarantees about problems
that are difficult to think about
analytically so at the kind of core idea
that the learning in the title of my
talk here is the idea of what we call an
empirical hardness model and that the
idea of an empirical hardness model is
to and essentially treat an algorithm
analysis as a natural science problem to
say you know I've got this black box
algorithm I don't really know what it
does inside but I can run it on problems
that I care about and measure its
runtime and
deserve what happened and and let me
then try to think about the problem of
analysis as being able to predict what
it's going to do on inputs that I
haven't yet given it and so I can set
this whole thing up as a machine
learning problem I can say let me get
some some given set of distances given
distribution of instances sampled from
some instance distribution and so some
sad and then for each of these instances
i can compute some set of features which
is going to be some real vector of
different measurements about the
instance that can be done in sort of
lowered or polynomial time and then also
i can actually run my algorithm and and
label this instance with a runtime
observation so yeah
this is assumption that the instances
are coming from a fixed stationary
distribution that's indeed not not
hidden and I'm trying to be a quite
upfront about that but that's exactly
the setting i want to think about so so
if i'm going to do something statistical
i'm not going to be able to speak about
how my instances do you know in some
totally different setting that i have no
data to describe so so instead i want to
speak about a distribution absolutely
contra say for the ordinance center
which underlying generation absolutely
yes so here I really want to think about
there being some right here you could
imagine if I cared about online settings
I could each setting might be a sample
and I could see many such settings but
but I want my I instances in some sense
to be Heidi and and and you know indeed
not every algorithm design problem looks
like this but I would argue that many do
and if you find yourself in one of these
problems then really that you face a
supervised learning problem there's
there's now kind of a regression problem
that says I want to find a mapping from
whatever it is that I can measure about
each instance cheaply to the the runtime
of my algorithm so if I any such mapping
is a kind of prediction that can be made
about every new instance that I see I'm
saying how long that algorithm will take
to run and this so that's what I'm going
to call an empirical hardness model it's
such a mapping and the question is you
know is it possible to do this at all
like it does it even make sense to think
that you could do this for an
np-complete problem and you know how
well does this work and how robustly
does this work so that's that's the
first question that I want to
investigate if you're a machine learning
type you might immediately sort of latch
on to the fact that i'm talking about
different approaches to regression and
think you know what your sexy regression
method are you using you know show using
gaussian processes or deep learning or
what have you and we've tried in over
the years a whole variety of different
methods I think our kind of high-level
message is that it makes a bit of a
difference which method you use but it's
not really a story about methods the
features are
important as is often the case in
machine running and I'll speak about the
future I'll finish my sentence speak up
with the features more in a moment but
um but most of what I'll speak about
today and will concern random for a
simple brush and trees which are a
robust class of machine learning models
which has the advantage that it deals
very nicely with discontinuities which
turns out to be important in this domain
yeah it's a little bit about what kind
how you discover these features I mean
one for all say a bit about it at the
end and what I'll say now is that mostly
you know we'll look at the theory
literature and we'll look at the kinds
of quantities that turn out to matter in
parameterize complexity analyses or
unity in various kinds of proofs that
people make about these kinds of
problems what are the things that I
could cheaply measure you know like what
kind of graph can i compute based on
this instance and then what structural
properties of the graph might be
interesting or what relaxations exist
for the problem and you know what can I
measure about the solution to the
relaxation things like that and and I'll
be more concrete at the end and but I'll
say that you know typically what we've
done is spend a week kind of just
combing the literature for sort of
everything get an exhaustive list of
features and then rely on machine
learning methods that can throw away
unnecessary features and typically that
that's worked very well for us so we
haven't found that we need to very
carefully engineer this set of features
at least nothing that I'll show you has
depended on that kind of engineering any
other questions I'm by the way very
happy to be interrupted during the talk
so please don't hold yourselves back
no so each and each X is a problem that
we're trying to solve is any better said
you know so f is a learned model so so
each each X is a menso so basically what
I'm interested in is these these
instances and then for each instance I
I'm going to measure some properties of
that instance and what I want to do is
so you know this this distribution of
instances might all be independent set
problems or sad problems or you know
whatever whatever they are I'm you know
I'm going to generate the constraint
graph and you know dude do whatever
things I do to get my vector of features
and then I'm going to try to find a
machine learning model that given those
features predict how long such a problem
would take to write I the coordinates of
the effects of the physical effects or
the eye is the instance so the eye is
the instance the X is the name I'm
giving to the vector corresponding to
Alex it's like for every instance use
different features we're gonna say for
each instance well I've got to actually
be able to compute these features so i
will have a different vector for every
instance so well the first element and
the vector might be what is the average
degree in the constraint graph
corresponding to that instance it's asim
dimensionality so features the
difference a different such values yes
but think of it as a constant
dimensional vector ok um so so here's
kind of a overall summary of what we
found in maybe 15 years of
experimentation on this sort of family
of problems and we basically you know
the op shot I wouldn't be standing here
talking to you today if it wasn't the
case that we found that these methods
work really reliably across a really
broad range of instances and and indeed
we started out doing this with a really
not very ambitious goal of tuning an
instance generator for combinatorial
auctions we thought this was going to be
terrible but maybe good enough they
would correlate with something and we
became really surprised by how well it
worked and this led us down
garden path of thinking more and more
deeply about this problem and so now
we've we've thought a lot about
satisfiability mixed integer programming
Traveling Salesman problem and
combinatorial oxfords which is where we
began we've looked at dozens of
different solvers including black box
commercial solvers in a state of the art
solvers everywhere and many dozens of
instance distributions looking at
benchmarks proposed by other people
various real-world data so really our
goal is to think about hard problems and
both incidents distributions and solvers
that there's some kind of external
reason to care about and here's some you
know I could show you graphs and you dig
into the analysis for my whole talk
which I'm not going to do but here are
some examples of what results look like
for us so at the the top here I'm
showing you two different distributions
on sat and on the bottom here I'm
showing you two different distributions
for mixed integer programming and let me
walk you through it each of these things
means so on the x-axis here I've got the
actual runtime what was the first of all
before I even show you this I should say
what we do is we gather a whole bunch of
data in the way that I described to you
and we we label that data by actually
running our algorithm on each of these
instances we get a training set then we
have another set of instances which
we've randomly partitioned from the data
that we were given which we also gather
runtime observations on but which we set
aside as a test set and all of the
results that I'm showing you here our
evaluations of the model trend on the
training set evaluated on the test set
so in every one of these cases the model
only gets to observe the future values
for some instance that it never actually
got to see in training and then we see
how well the prediction of the model
matches up against the actual thing that
happened and so every one of these dots
in the graph corresponds to such a run
of test data yeah so to get enough data
maybe you have a generative model or are
these real licenses so there it differs
I think maybe all of these are real life
instances and but we certainly also
sometimes work with generators what
would your animals you would expect that
there's a small number of parameters
that sort of give away what's going on
but it's interesting that you might I
think
I think if you push harder on that it's
it's not always the case that the things
you're measuring about the algorithm
lined up very well with those parameters
but but but indeed that might be I mean
as it happens the four examples I've got
here are you know every problem that was
ever entered in the SAT competition
through all of the different tracks is
that graph this is real problems from
Hardware verification and with a
particular SAT solver and this is
something and on protecting habitat for
red quested woodpeckers and solved with
cplex and encoded as MIPS and this is at
all of MIT lib which was this wildly
heterogeneous a library of MIT data that
the MIT community has assembled so all
of these are data sets that came from
you know they don't have some clean
analytic generating process yeah they
all the same size or the issues not at
all are you something like niblet for
example there's wild variation in size
as there is an aside competition it's I
think it's a competition problems vary
from you know being maybe a few k to
like 500 megabytes as the size of the
input instance they're really wild
wildly wildly different sizes what can
be slow is both time and complexity for
a given instance like you know an
instance can be harder an instance can
be big and both of those things like
sometimes the big instances are really
easy there's none s it's time size is
not necessarily a monotonic predictor of
hardness in these crazy heterogeneous
distributions yeah yes youtube users for
a given solver absolutely that's on my
next slide so let me let me defer it
lets right now quietly think about this
question of one solver because i think
it's still quite surprising that you
could say something about what cplex is
going to do I mean even if I fix one
particular cplex I think that to me that
was that was quite a surprising thing
already and and so I just want to
continue kind of walk you through these
graphs mean so you know what we would
want to see is all of the points on the
legis what I haven't said yet is it here
i'm looking at run x varying on a log
scale right so so this is a runtime that
took 10 to the minus 3 seconds which is
like a millisecond this is 10 to the 4
seconds which is like a day or something
so we have very you
really really enormous runtime variation
on these plots and what we would like to
see is all of the points lined up
exactly along the blue line that would
mean I made a run time prediction and
then here's my prediction and it was
exactly whatever the actual album
runtime was if I look at how much they
vary along this part that's just telling
me the actual variation in run times
that I had in that distribution yeah are
the vertical dots there's some artifact
looking things of vertical dot you know
yeah those are cut offs so it wasn't
possible for us to run you know I said
that's a day I don't know if it's
actually a day or it's like half a day
or something but you know each of these
points is incredibly expensive to
compute right I have to spend an actual
like many many hours on a computer
cluster just to get that one point and
so you know at some point we just have
to stop and so in fact in there's a
machine learning question there which is
how do you build unbiased models from
sensor data we've actually written a
couple of papers about that because
that's pretty important in this context
I'm not going to get into the details
but but you will notice that the data is
censored and that's that's not a mistake
the downward lying that's actually where
the prediction was such as no no I
horizontal line would be a constant
prediction right so this is this is a
censorship in measurement that really
these would have gone further out and
something else you'll notice if you have
a really good eye is some striping here
on the left side and that's resolution
of the CPU timer when we get into very
small rent ons um so that's that's a
different kind of measurement error the
vertical line on the left that's grossly
underestimated so the vertical line on
the left and I'm sorry on the right yes
so this is a case where the runtime is
is something much larger and all we're
observing is a bound on the run time and
your estimate was somewhere quite low
yes and so here you know in this
particular case and what we're using
random forest models which don't
extrapolate so they can never give a
larger value than they've seen so we
would never go above this point because
there's nothing in the data that's
bigger than that point so we can only
expect this stuff here in below and in a
scatter plot you don't see density well
so you
have a good sense of how what a large
fraction of our stuff is there versus
there so but if we look at the root mean
squared error which is actually pretty
small in this example it gives us a
sense that that our eye is being misled
by this line it's not as big as it looks
like it is and but but so you know
broadly speaking what I and I should say
these are some pretty challenging and
problems because in particular both of
these ones are really heterogeneous
their sets of problem distributions of
sort of dozens of problem distributions
which in training data are pretty
sparsely sampled and so that that's why
we see bigger variation here that maybe
doesn't surprise us so much in this
column we're looking at something that
looks more like the problem a
practitioner would have of studying one
domain and seeing how it works well I
should say this is one of the best
results we've ever seen this isn't
typical but this kind of result is
typical so so we really do tend to see
just pretty accurately predicted run
times you know even across really a wide
variation and you know I guess what I
want to leave you with this notion that
this is possible to do I subject to some
error yes this is see flips with one all
these dogs corresponds it seems setting
yes this is see plexi and running on its
default settings so we just take the
take the map throw it at cplex and see
how long it took okay but but you guys
are clamoring for more settings so let's
talk about that so so here I've been
talking about black box algorithms but
you can then as many people have been
doing at this workshop think about
parameterised algorithm families and and
so here we can basically say I've got my
features that describe the instance and
I've also got the algorithm parameters
and let me now build a model in both of
those things and and because we're doing
this in a statistical way we're going to
be very generous about how these
parameters can behave we're going to
allow them to be continuous or discrete
ordinal or categorical you know cplex
has some things where it's like auto or
a continuous values you can have these
funny discontinuities where Auto has
very special meaning and everything else
is continuous you can have parameters
that are conditional where some
parameter gets turned on only in the
context of some other parameter having a
certain value so our models are going to
allow all of this sort of thing and to
establish terminology i'm going to call
full parameter instantiations which
correspond to what we were looking at in
the previous slide and
with an algorithm configuration and so
in the context of the previous couple of
talks for us the the problem of looking
at a design space of algorithms given by
parameters and finding one that performs
well in a distribution is what our
literature called the algorithm
configuration problem so but here I'm
not going to think about solving the
configuration problem i'm just going to
think about building an empirical
hardness model that performs well as we
vary the set of of instances and also
the set of configurations so what i'm
going to do is various other businesses
and configurations in my training data
and then at test time i'm going to
consider both instances and
configurations that I've never seen
before so that's a pretty hard problem
you can imagine varying either only want
one or the other but here I'm going to
vary both and again you know we have a
giant paper that does a really
exhaustive analysis of this but here is
some suggestive pictures it to let you
know what it looks like so here again is
Miss Webb here again is the IBM
verification data but now we're looking
at every one of these points corresponds
to an algorithm that hasn't been seen
before in training data and you know
from this fixed space and also an
instance it hasn't been seen before and
you know what you see is that you know
the pictures are not as pretty as before
we're getting a bigger variation it's
important to look at these root mean
squared error numbers because again your
eye tends to get drawn to outliers in a
scatter plot but you know we're still
getting root mean squared error of less
than one and bear in mind it if an
algorithm made an order of magnitude
error in predicting runtime on every
instance it would have a root mean
squared error of one so what's that
we're did this should make you think
that on average we're doing considerably
better than predicting the order of
magnitude and we have variation across
many orders of magnitude there and so
again my hope here is that you're left
with the sense that this is possible to
do subject to some error yeah ridah
absolutely and that's and that's another
thing we've studied that's what these
previous talks have really focused on
you're trying to establish you know how
many instances you need you know we
don't know the pseudo dimension of these
problems so i can't tell you something
analytic about it but you know typically
what we do is we just overdo it yeah we
we try to just gather a lot of data you
know computers are cheap and grad
students are expensive so we just try to
gather a lot of data and not have to
think about it too hard yeah well just
the Faubourg by sat you mean finding
those satisfied will affect so the
subproblem I'm going to talk about is
here's a SAT formula find me some
satisfying assignment and the MIT
problem i'm looking at is here's a
mixed-integer program find me the
optimal solution and prove that it's not
to India given that there's a satisfying
the same with no no so you might also be
asked to prove that there does not exist
a sensing something I don't think any of
the distributions that I'm looking at
here is purely satisfiable although
there are some distributions we've
studied there um okay so so that that's
you know what I wanted to say about
empirical hardness models I just really
want to tell you we've got this crazy
thing you know we can use machine
learning to make pretty statistically
robust predictions of how some black box
algorithm is going to work on some
realistic family of NP complete problems
what can we then do with that if we have
such a thing and well I guess you know I
told you learning as a tool for
algorithm design and Beyond worst-case
analysis so so here's the part where I
want to tell you how we can use this
thing as a tool for algorithm design and
the first sensor which we can use it is
for this problem that i'm calling
algorithm configuration let me say you
know over the last you know decades but
you know continuing over the last 10 or
15 years moore's law has just been
marching on right this is the the
moore's law graph and and what this
means is that we have even though your
laptop hasn't really gotten any faster
this is this is your laptop this is the
clock speed of a computer that you can
buy that's kind of flatlined since about
two thousand but you know the computers
in the data center have just more and
more transistors and so for the same
cost and so what that means is you're
able to
do you know crazy things on clusters of
computers that just wouldn't have made
sense to do 10 or 15 years ago I think
that's indeed where the deep learning
kind of breakthrough has come in you
know deep learning can really be
understood as saying look machine
learning used to say you know come up
with your features very carefully
thinking about it as an expert tune your
model family by hand turn your hyper
parameters with little experiments and
really you know the deep learning people
said computers have gotten fast enough
that we can actually do something crazy
here we can have really highly
parametrized models that rely very
little on expert knowledge they're deep
in the sense of having many layers of
parameters that depend on previous
parameters we can we can survive having
lots of data and as long as we
regularize appropriately and then we can
just search this crazy thing using all
of these transistors that are now at our
disposal we can spend days and days
running on clusters of GPUs and we can
actually fit models and and you know
there's a little bit of nice Theory
that's happened in deep learning but I
think even the kind of people working in
this area will argue that this is mostly
a story about computational power that
being the case you might wonder what
does that mean for us if we study
optimization I would argue that there's
a kind of analogous deep optimization
program that one can follow so the way
people in the kind of AI community think
about attacking some problem demand that
that is important to attack is you know
an expert comes up with a heuristic
algorithm based on all kinds of
knowledge of heuristics things that have
worked in the past and then they
iteratively do small experiments to
improve the design they kind of iterate
in this way until the conference
deadline and then they submit what
they've got and that's their algorithm
and instead of what you know we've been
advocating for some time now is what you
might call deep optimization because it
looks very much like deep learning so we
could instead think of our algorithm
design spaces as being very highly
parameterised by all of the heuristic
design choices that you might have ever
thought of making and they can be deep
in the sense that there can be many
levels of parameters in the algorithms
that could be parameters about you know
which algorithm family do you use and
then which algorithm in the family to
use conditional on the algorithm and
then which sub heuristics given the
algorithm and which parameters of those
sub us tix so you so we've really come
up with some
design spaces that are four or five
levels deep in this sense the same kind
of beat it's not um i would say these
parameters depending you define new
parameters depending on order that's
what I'm saying exactly that's what you
do right so what's the example that I
just gave you of an algorithm family and
then an algorithm and then a heuristic
of that algorithm and then a parameter
of that heuristic each of those
parameters has meaning based on the
parameters that come before now the
center which is different is we're not
having these things be identified by the
model right we're coming up with this
ourselves so that is the sentiment it's
different and I I don't want to gloss
over that difference but but the sense
in which it's so similar really is again
we use a lot of data and again we
resolve this space by leveraging this
large amount of computation I mean in
the end we want to find an algorithm in
this space that performs well rather
than finding a model that predicts well
and the underlying problem is a little
bit different and you could indeed
wonder you know to what extent can you
actually do representation learning in
this domain there might be ways of
pushing the analogy further but but I
think you know what similar is that
people 10 or 15 years ago thought that
it just made absolutely no sense to to
you know statistically study suplexes
design space by looking at terrible
parameter configurations and seeing how
they aren't finding gradients and this
has become possible to do sort of for
the same reasons let me tell you a
little bit about what we would do and
some methods are based on gradients and
some are not but but but when one way or
another you want to search this based if
I'm minima in the space and so so indeed
the algorithm configuration problem is
is the the problem of answering your
question I'm saying how do I want to
search this space and as an aside I want
to say I think this is a pretty
interesting algorithm algorithms problem
that should interest all of you and so
our input is all of the parameters that
encode the design choice and that my
algorithm designer came up with and what
I what I want to do is basically
automated experiment design so I want to
find some parameter configuration with
good performance by making black box
calls to this parameter space and then
making observations at any point that I
choose to observe and this is
because the design dimensions can be in
some cases continuous and in other cases
not continuous there's another design
dimension which is which instance do I
choose to test on where my objective
function cares about some aggregation
across all of the instances but I can
for example choose to do a blocked
experiment design where I keep looking
at the same instance over and over again
to reduce variants my objective function
to be minimized is something like the
average run time and that's interesting
because the cost of evaluating a given
point also depends on the average run
time so if I look at a really good point
it's very cheap for me to make an
observation if I look at a terrible
point it's very expensive for me to make
an observation so I don't have a uniform
cost structure where I'm going to be
limited to some finite number of points
but instead I have a time budget and in
fact i can even and reason it kind of
strategic about that time budget so i
can say i'm going to choose to evaluate
this particular point but only for a
second and if nothing comes back after a
second i will have learned a bound and
and if it's below a second great i've
learned something good because i'm
trying to minimize something and and i
can and that number a second of course i
actually get to reason about that my
algorithm can be dynamic about choosing
what that number should be so this whole
kind of black box optimization problem I
think it's a very interesting one
there's I think room for some deep
theory and thinking about this and
there's a little bit of theory already
and drawing them kind of bandit ideas
but i think a lot more can be done and
so let me tell you the the current
methods that we use which are based on
this idea of the fact that it's possible
to do runtime modeling and this picture
that i'm going to show you is based on
gaussian processes because in one
dimension gaussian processes give it a
prettier picture but we actually use
random forests so so here's here's the
real problem so let's say this blue line
here is the actual algorithm run time
that you know across the parameter space
so the x-axis here is different
parameters the y-axis is how expensive
is the algorithm given those parameters
and what I want to do is find the best
algorithm and so I want to minimize this
blue function but I don't get to see the
blue function this is something I only
get to have kind of Oracle access to by
doing a run and so each of these circles
is a place where I've previously done a
run and
the solid black line is the mean of a
Gaussian process across these samples so
you can see it's confident where it's
seen a sample and it has error bars
which are these dashed lines away from
places where it's seen a sample this
close so this could think of this is the
average across instances because my
objective function is going to be the
average across censuses so so I'm going
to need to again this is kind of a
cartoon the real algorithm has to be
more complicated has too many dimensions
to put on a slide but but think about
this as an average across instances and
so then I'm going to have an acquisition
function here the acquisition function
is the expected improvement over the
best thing that I've seen so far so
right now this is the best thing that
I've seen so far and the expected
improvement of every point is saying
conditional on your run time being
better than this how good do I think you
are and because these are Gaussian
processes there gaussians everywhere so
there's always some probability mass
kind of out to very low run times and so
I'm going to show you a video now that
shows you how this thing actually runs
so it begins by saying let me let me
look here and then you know it kind of
keeps going to the place with the best
expected improvement and then updating
the model iteratively and so eventually
what we get is you know a bunch of
samples in a place that looks good and
we don't waste our time sampling places
that look bad because the error bars in
our model tell us that there's nothing
worth looking at there and so so that's
kind of how this approach called Beijing
optimization works well there's a
smoothness assumption to the Gaussian
process the as I said you know we're
using a model random forests that
doesn't make a smooth this assumption it
models the space as being piecewise
constant and so we have discontinuous
jobs when we have discontinuous
parameters that's a good assumption to
make when I show it to you in one
dimension it looks kind of ridiculous
because you just sort of see a staircase
so that's why this example doesn't
doesn't doesn't look like that but they
but broadly speaking this is called
bajan optimization because we have sort
of a posterior belief over how good my
algorithm is you know everywhere in the
perimeter space including points that I
haven't observed
and then we reason about that
distribution to decide how to solve this
active learning problem of looking where
to where to go next and the algorithm
that we've actually proposed in our
group is called a sequential model based
algorithm configuration and it's
essentially the same sort of idea based
on a random forest model and thinking
about problems like the one you raised
about how do we actually think about
which instances to pick how do we think
about this this runtime capping problem
so I'm not going to go through the
details of how this thing works but but
essentially it's a it's it's kind of
like what you would expect given what I
told you so far um and let me just say
you know we've produced this thing as
open source software we've released it
publicly since I think maybe in the past
five years and it's been really widely
used both by us and by others to have
really practical impacts in a lot of
different problems so here's just some
examples of places by by us and by
others where this approach has been used
to to tune algorithms and achieve better
performance than people were able to
achieve by hand and so that's what I
want to say about configuration let me
say something about another idea called
algorithm portfolios um and and this is
typically what we mean when we say
algorithm selection we mean you know
even when I get down to sort of good SAT
solvers that people have bothered to
identify by hand it's typically the case
that there isn't a best one the
different solvers work well on different
instances and this gets to the the
question that that already was asking in
the last talked you know maybe rather
than and just running you know having to
commit in advance to one thing that has
the best average performance across my
distribution I should instead kind of
take a portfolio approach where I mean
if I'm able to predict runtimes
accurately I could predict runtimes for
every one of these different solvers and
run the one that was predicted to be
best or alternately if I have a lot of
parallel computation available to me
maybe I would just run a set of solvers
that look good in parallel and then that
that whole process would terminate as
soon as the first of them terminated and
so back in 2003 we made a SAT solver
called SAT Zilla
which is graphically depicted here and
and it basically has has done really
really really well in this ad community
since that community has these sad
competitions and and we we just
basically destroyed SAT competitions by
taking other people SAT solvers which I
have to say I didn't even deeply
understand we just basically took kind
of machine learning and wrapped it
around other people's stuff you know
telling them that this is what we were
doing and we just kept winning the
competition's because it was you know
because portfolio is a really good idea
that right that's why you should all buy
an index fund like it it's just much
better than you know trying to just find
one thing that you think is going to
work really well so enemy and it
basically in the competition's we just
did spectacularly well until they
decided they were pissed off at us and
they banned portfolios well you know I
guess there's there's no academic glory
to be had by breaking the rules of the
competition and then telling them that
you did that so that's kind of having in
for said yeah this is I mean machine
running ensemble methods uh it's a lot
like an ensemble method and the way that
it's different is that if you think
about something like boosting every
element in the ensemble gets evaluated
and then you vote with a portfolio you
don't want to get the measurements from
the guys that are slow that's the whole
problem so you kind of only want you to
run one of them or you've paid far too
much but actually and the second paper
that I wrote on this topic was called
boosting as a metaphor for algorithm
design so so I think indeed the
connection goes pretty deep but it's not
as direct as you might better um oven
which is just what just be sure so we're
doing here is you're given the instance
you spent a little bit of time to
evaluate features that shouldn't
hopefully not take too much time right
and you pay that up front so that you
throw that time away use that to choose
one algorithm yes they just go with that
that's right um I did when we really
want to win the competition we we have a
couple of others sort of complicated
engineering ideas that make things work
a little bit better but it for this
purpose that that's not interesting so
so let's just say that's what we do
you were saying there's another waste
time which is evaluating on the show you
the features of features nobody has it
features now you want you can rate the
model the most that's correct typically
the models much cheaper to evaluate than
the features so so I think to a first
order of ribs story was right but but
yes we have to pay all the costs machine
tools I want a machine the leap to that
is faster prediction yes which typically
they are in particular random forests
are basically you know a tree data
structure where you look up the point
you want to find so they're very fast at
evaluation time and and you know I again
I think this is interesting and just a
kind of as a general recipe more more
than you know analyzing exactly how fast
where we had some distribution so so I
kind of just want to leave you with this
idea that we can you know this again has
worked very generally across different
domains something I think that's really
enticing about it is it shows that there
are some solvers that people had called
uncompetitive that you know used to be
great like a decade ago and they really
fallen out of favor and our analysis has
shown that they actually they're really
great to have in a portfolio because on
like ten percent of the instances that
really uncorrelated and they're really
fast and they're utterly terrible the
rest of the time but we don't care if
they're terrible because we can predict
their terrible and actually in some of
our most recent work with we've thought
about how to use ideas from cooperative
game theory to use the the Shapley value
to say how how valuable is each solver
to a portfolio we want to argue that's
actually how you should really think
about the value of an algorithm in the
context of all the other algorithms
rather than just in this kind of scandal
own way and so yeah that seems also like
a whale feature selection I mean this um
well it's not features in the in the
sense that I had before but I think
actually even the thing I'm about to say
next maybe will feel even more like that
to you so let me let me say the next
thing and so everything I've said you
might notice some sort of cognitive
dissonance between my first application
and my second one ride with
configuration I said let's do this
automated design where we find some
point of the design space that maybe
would be surprising to a practitioner
and then
portfolios I said I'm given some small
set of known to be good algorithms and I
want to choose among them in some good
way you might think you know why did you
give up on this automated algorithm
design idea that you had and so we have
an approach called Hydra which is a
marriage of these two ideas and
basically it says let's imagine that I
have some enormous design space and I
want to ultimately come up with not one
good algorithm but a portfolio that
works well as a portfolio from this
design space and basically this works
really well essentially what it does is
we change the performance metric that
we're optimizing for iteratively so this
is a you can think of this is a sub
modular optimization problem where I
started saying you know what's the best
thing to add to a portfolio of size zero
that's the thing I would have picked in
the first instance then when I'm looking
for the second algorithm to add I say I
already know that I've got the first guy
so i don't i don't care if my second
algorithm is worse than the first guy
because i'll just use the first guy but
I care about him being better sometimes
and so I say you know who is the
algorithm that makes the biggest
marginal contribution to my existing
portfolio and that's that's my new
objective function so every time it's
worse than the portfolio i'm just going
to score it as the portfolio i try to
maximize that i produce the second
algorithm at i can iterate this as many
times as i like until you're diminishing
marginal returns means that i just stop
finding anything and um let me give you
a very yeah so I mean this is really the
analog of deep learning right so now you
can propagate back which features were
good right or which combinations of
features I'd love to talk to you about
that more because I still think we don't
do nearly as much with features as we
might let me take that offline but I
think this is at least taking steps in
that direction yeah that was an obvious
next step right yeah I think that that's
right yeah like send a feedback back to
the features right and eliminate
features of take combination it would be
very nice to see that working yeah
question both sides in us so how large
was
does that you computed from the SAT
solvers so typically something on the
order of like 100 plus or minus 50
something like that that's evolved over
the competitions yeah I mean it evolved
kind of it just strictly grew you know
random forests are a feature selection
method if there's a future that's not
helping they just don't choose it so
they deal very robustly with lots of
useless features so every time you know
we read a new theory paper or somebody
came up to us after talk with a good
idea we sort of would add those to the
set of feature back in the future back
then did you go back and look at them
and try to understand why certainly yes
if time permits which I'm not sure that
it well I'll tell you a bit at the end
about what we can do in that vein but
that's that's the beyond worst-case
analysis part of my promise to you which
I think i will not not satisfied okay so
i think we'll we'll get just to the very
beginning of that but what's up yeah if
you can we can talk about it in the
discussion sessions afterwards i'm so
lonely tell you and this actually going
to be pretty quick but i just want to
show you that this all works so you
already heard earlier this morning about
at the FCC's and spectrum repacking and
task that they're they're currently
doing and and you know I turn out to
have led the team that actually designed
the algorithm that is being used in this
auction to solve this graph coloring
problem that the reverse auction
repeatedly needs to solve and a quick
shout out to all of the people both at
UBC at auction ah miix which is an
auction consulting company and the FCC
who made this work possible this was a
giant project so thanks to all of these
people and basically and the FCC had
designed a very complicated auction
simulator which produced many instances
from from different simulation
assumptions and different random runs of
the simulator that that were kind of
realistic problems that might be
encountered in an auction we don't know
everything about the auction but we know
we know many of the parameters we know
that the different clearing targets that
could be possible we know the
populations that stations serve so we
know a decent valuation model for the
stations and we know the actual
underlying constraint network that
really will be used in the real auction
because we know the actual
television stations in the United States
so so these simulations are not perfect
and in fact I can't tell you how
imperfect they are because the auction
which is currently going on right now
it's actually secret I personally am not
allowed to know the results of how my
solver is doing but but we do know that
it's running on the same constraint
network and two years after it ends I'll
get to look at the data along with all
of you and we can find out how we did
but and but basically these graph
coloring problems we have to solve a
graph coloring problem every time some
station is being offered a price
movement right every time I go to one
station and I say I previously made you
some offer now I want to make you a
lower offer that corresponds to a graph
coloring problem and and because I have
to do this in sequence and there's like
three thousand stations and the FCC is
willing for us to have a one-minute cut
off in each of these graph coloring
problems and it's okay if we don't solve
all of the problems every time I fail to
solve a problem I have to be
conservative and does not let the price
move but that usually means that I'm
leaving money on the table and so the
goal is to leave his little money on the
table as possible and so when I first
got involved in the project the FCC was
looking at mixed integer programming
solutions to this problem I'm not
allowed to show you exactly what they
were using but here are cplex and goro
be and running on on all of our data now
I'm going to be again using machine
learning methods here so I'm going to be
training my methods on a training set
and then evaluating them on a test set
so all of my graph see our test set
performance I'm not actually training
anything about see place and grove if it
nevertheless this is my test set so what
I'm showing you here is a cumulative
empirical cumulative distribution that
says within this amount of time what
fraction of my test set instance has got
solved and so what I'd like to see is
that this thing goes right up to one and
stays there that would mean I sold
everything really really fast and what
you can see is sort of the opposite
thing where it stays really close to the
bottom until the end this is my 1-minute
color and so you can see within the
minute goro be is solving about ten
percent of the instances and see parts
of solving about a quarter of the
instances and that's really really
terrible you couldn't run an auction
this way because that means a quarter of
the price movements are possible to make
that means most people are not even
getting
you know they're stuck at the reserve
prices really really terrible so you the
auction would not have gone forward with
solver performance like this our first
kind of inside was that this looked a
lot more like a soft problem to us than
like a mitt problem because its graph
coloring there's no real values there's
no objective function and so we took
just everything from the sad competition
and we ran everything and here's how all
the different SAT solvers did a lot
better I'm here here's CC button grow be
for comparison and the best thing with
the local search algorithm which which
is not too surprising because most of
our problems are satisfiable and it
doesn't matter that much if we prove on
satisfiability and but you know still
not good enough look this is maybe
two-thirds of the instances solved that
still leaves a ton of money on the table
and the next thing we did was we
configured all of these solvers to see
how they did using smack that was a lot
of work but I'm not going to tell you
about it I was going to show you the
best thing that happened so here's clasp
which you can see is just in the sea of
different solvers here it's not
particularly fantastic but class was
designed by its authors to be really
amenable to this kind of deep
optimization approach and so you can see
after configuration we end up with a
class solver which is designed for the
u.s. interference graph of the graph
coloring problem and it turns out to be
fantastic on that graph so we're getting
up now to sort of seventy-five percent
of the instances then we basically use
hydro so we then tried to build an
algorithm portfolio of many different
solvers starting with this class
configuration that would do as well as
possible along with a lot of other
algorithms sir problem specific ideas
that we introduced as new parameters
which I don't have time to tell you
about but here's the upshot we ended up
with an eight algorithm portfolio of all
of these different algorithms the red
line is they is the performance of the
eight algorithms running in parallel and
you can see it's fantastically better
than then it would have been otherwise
so I'm not going to be able to tell you
about my last section but let me Spencer
30 seconds telling you what you're
missing so what I would have told you
about is ok if I've got a model that
that makes good predictions you can
think about this model as a starting
point for theoretical analysis you could
actually look at which features are
driving the model try to take them apart
and say you know what can I learn about
what's important to this solvers
performance and this
setting by looking at how the model
works and most ridiculously I would have
told you about the fact that we can
actually directly predict satisfiability
status on uniform random three cell
problems at the phase transition and we
can that prediction I'm just going to
skip ahead here to to do so many fun
things you're missing but but but this
ridiculously simple model which is a
decision tree with two variables in it
is able to predict at about seventy
percent accuracy how well a solver will
do on uniform random free sat at the
phase transition ranging from problems
that are super super simple to problems
that take about a day to run and trained
only on these ones and I think this
might be an interesting starting point
for theoretical analysis because this
model is so simple you can actually
think about it it involves and the
really determinative feature in it is
and the coefficient of variation in the
slack vector of the LP relaxation so I'm
happy to talk about that more afterwards
but I wanted just to show you this at
least as a cartoon to give you a sense
of you know what might this look like as
a jumping-off point for theory so with
that thanks for your attention and I'm
happy to chat over lunch
after lunch too I guess it's just ache
let's just all go beep I think that's
the right choice yeah let's you've got
to for the but i wonder if Avram wants
to say something or if I want to say
something about how the breakouts are
gonna work so we're gonna have three
different breakout sessions after lunch
they are going to be I guess I'm going
to be leading one which is the easiest
one for me to describe because I'm
leading it which is going to be on kind
of data-driven approaches for algorithm
analysis so sure algorithm design so my
hope is that you know people both from
theoretical perspectives and kind of
statistical perspectives will have a
conversation about what it makes sense
to do to do algorithm design in ways
that are informed directly by real data
Avram is going to be chairing a second
session which he will tell me what it's
called let's see so vulgar agreed to
enjoy mean what we'll talk about the
properties of real world instances of
what could we try to hope to are there
so the properties that seemed to make
algorithms work well and we could you
know maybe try to develop theory about
you know whether people see and what
might be some things we might you know
in terms of assumptions that one might
try to write down and hope to prove some
theorems while you're at it why don't
you tell us also about the third one
third one will be saanchi you slipped
away which is what you have to tell us
about it well which you will find out it
two o'clock so i think i think our aim
with sanjeev's one was that it was going
to be relatively more theoretically
oriented because these two were
relatively less theoretically oriented
and it would also have more of a
learning flavor and I don't remember
exactly the mission statement that he
picked if indeed he had settled on it
the idea is gonna be that we're gonna
have three different locations will have
signs telling you where they are but
will have three different locations
maybe we should all meet it to will sort
of dispatch everybody and you figure out
where to go we're going to three
different locations you can come and go
between the different sessions the
breakup will last for an hour and a half
then we'll have a talk by an out of 20
minutes and don't take too long although
i haven't talked by sharpie I think and
then we will
have sort of the three groups come
together and the chairs will sort of
report back what you heard in the group
so we can all hear what happened and so
see you after lunch thanks